dramatic adventures though one thing
i've always been curious about is how do
you guys like pick the guests
to like bring over and showcase to
people is there like a process behind
that or
for my company there was at that time
when i was
like the event person in shock in charge
of
um we would look first at the sales
right like oh what's trending
what's like the top selling manga or
light novel the top ten and then i just
contacted them yeah yeah and because i'm
in book walker and book walkers like has
really close ties to all different kinds
of publishers
yeah um i guess we're able to ask
them yeah yeah i mean yeah because that
makes sense because i
because i've done so many like creator
panels yeah especially at ax with bulk
walker
i did it with like domaci goblin slayer
yeah um and every time i remember like
every time one of those panels finish
always one person who comes up to me for
some reason of all people and it's like
hey next year can you get uh the author
of this
uh light novel that'd be really cool did
you ever get people who
thought you were the author of something
yeah yeah i had that yeah i've had that
really
yeah someone came up to my thing this
okay this is back when uh the 93
was still a thing oh yeah yeah some some
guy like
13 year old boy came up to me that's
weird why is there a guy in my line
[Laughter]
so he comes up to me he's like oh yeah
yeah he took took a photo did the
signings like you're the author of
goblin slayer right
no kidding i was like no because we had
autographs at our booth
and he was like you're the author of
goblins saying like do you want to look
like japanese like what
no no i get i don't get a lot of you're
the author but i always get a lot of
like you're the guy who does the
official translations
like because he translated like the or
what the author was saying yeah yeah
you must and yeah i had i remember i had
a guy just being like um
when's like uh like volume three of
goblins like gonna get translated
like i [ __ ] know you should just been
like yeah actually tomorrow
yeah i'm working on it right now
actually don't worry it's coming soon if
you just left me alone it would have
been done
yeah no but again yeah but i guess so
many people just being like hey can you
bring on
this creator or like this author i'm
just like
don't ask me i'm just i'm just hosting
it anime departments of like certain
companies
they usually bring guests of
like say directors or whatever of
whatever anime is coming out that season
and they have a premiere
and the author or director comes to
promote the premiere so not necessarily
it's like trending it's basically just
all marketing then
yes this is the way i see it yeah yeah
so it's all data it's all marketing
it's all data and marketing business
because i always wondered ax must be
really expensive to like put up all the
like the the booth the staff the
marketing is it like
i mean obviously it must be worth it
right like is there a return on
investment like huge there
i mean they're not really looking for
sales directly
right right i think it's just looking
for presents because if you don't have a
presence it's like not being at e3 you
know what i mean
i guess even companies now are like
questioning if e3 is worth it yeah
i mean like i mean sony wasn't at e3 the
year before i think and that was like
massive news because that was like a
massive statement being like hey we
we don't [ __ ] need e3 you know we're
[ __ ] sony
i wonder if that would be a thing with
that like ax when the company's like oh
we don't really need ax anymore right a
lot of
uh companies though or japanese
companies are bringing their own guests
instead of through the guest of honor
thing yeah
because i i feel like right now with and
with like anime growing so much in the
west i think it there is a
big like a big um like there's more eyes
at ax now yeah so like if you're not
there
then that's that's like that's like a
missed opportunity more than
hey this is e3 you know i mean this is
already established press
two yeah a lot of news sites are all at
this event so they could arrange
interviews
or whatever that could promote it